zere by this court's ruling that you
shall be detained in safe custody at
Broadmoor asylum for the criminally
insane we have been attempting to make
this dictionary the last 20 years the
task is gigantic and impossible there is
a way an appeal to the english-speaking
public will ask them to read in search
of the words that we want and get them
to write the word and the slip of paper
all words and their complete history
every last one the work is taking too
long
not a single page to show for it the
language is developing faster than our
progress it's a very card while they
sent us a savior
new volunteer who is it
so this is the good doctor I cannot
believe my eyes
we've only just started partners but for
what American and Scot brilliant man
which is which he gave us life he
doesn't belong here
he doesn't belong anywhere else he's a
murderer he lied to you William miner
will be struck from all acknowledgments
as a contributor to the dictionary
illness has entered a new phase you
think you're on the verge of all-out
translation we are watching with a
concerned i watch them and be amazed
every life deserves a chance
when I read no one is after me they can
fly out of this place on the backs of
books I came to see my friend a real
man's friend I am
madness yeah us words
[Music]
you